foreign
our buddies are over at Sofi which run
the little sweet little sweet nurturing
commercials about how much they love you
and then they sell you crappy Financial
products they got a nice Stadium though
oh gosh
everybody needs a nice Stadium if you're
gonna sell crappy stuff you should have
a nice stadium with all the profits you
make from your crappy stuff there you go
so what's up well now they're getting
into the student loan fight there's an
article that said Sofi Bank sues to
block Biden's student loan payment pause
so this is another lawsuit y'all and
it's not even just to stop the program
it's to stop the pause the article says
a private bank is trying to force the
Biden Administration to end its pause on
federal student loan payments arguing
the moratorium has no legal basis and
has cost the bank known for its
refinancing business millions of dollars
in profits about hundreds of millions
that just makes me want to throw up a
little bit right there like if you kind
of tells you what's going on now their
motivation obviously is so pure yeah it
says in the federal lawsuit filed Friday
in Washington Sofi Bank asked a federal
judge to overturn President Joe Biden's
latest extension on the payment pause
student loan loan payments were first
halted at the start of the pandemic by
President Trump the pause has been
extended eight times over the last three
years the bank says its federal student
loan refinancing business has suffered
because borrowers have little incentive
to refinance while payment while
payments and interests are on hold at a
minimum the lawsuit asks a judge to
limit the pause only to borrowers who
are eligible for the Biden cancellation
plan Biden's latest extension which was
announced in November and could stretch
as far as this summer is unlawful on
multiple grounds the lawsuit claims the
plan is currently being challenged in
the Supreme Court which is expected to
rule by June you know this is
interesting the um the extension uh the
pause was basically under emergency
times in a pandemic and it was emergency
Powers if you will granted to the
president to help things and it has
moved from him
uh Trump first and then later even Biden
helping people during the pandemic
uh make it through their student loans
it's moved from that as a motivation to
now I just don't want them to have to
pay their student loans so I'm just
going to kick the can and I'm the guy
that gets can do can do that but there's
no emergency anymore so I think kinda
even though I think so far is pretty
scummy um it probably sends for scummify
but the um but uh uh I think there's
probably a basis for the lawsuit I know
well and even it's not like you've it's
not like you can go we have to extend
the student loans because the pandemic
are like wait a minute it's over dude
it's over nobody's wearing a mask dude
fouchie's gone dude I mean really you
need to catch up because that's so 20
20. I mean really and you know it's like
he doesn't have that power on that basis
anymore well that's what they're even
saying with the whole cancellation plan
right now is he's trying to cancel it
you know based on what happened in the
pandemic and they're like that's that's
over like how can we cancel it based on
that so even so far in the Supreme Court
case there's a lot of skepticism from
the judges going wait a minute how does
this connect and how can you use this
reasoning if you're also saying the
pandemics over so that's the law the
education department comes out and says
it's an attempt by multi-million dollar
company to make money while they force
45 million dollar 45 million borrowers
back into payments which is actually
true
it is an attempt by a multi-million
multi-billion dollar company to collect
interest on the loans that they have and
also to get more people to refinance
which I'm like isn't that horrible
marking marketing to be like we're gonna
stop the pause and now you should come
when they were thinking about filing
this lawsuit did they not consult their
PR department yeah I'm like the lawsuit
Swift condemnation from borrower
Advocates who called it a money grab at
the expense of those struggling with
student loan debt
oh well it could be at the expense of
the taxpayers right now
and I didn't have a student loan debt
when all this started did you no um so
we're paying the interest right now
so
because you know this is it's not hey
yeah I think it's just important to
highlight too that these companies they
don't care about you as many there's
just no everybody in the article is evil
well it's like they're gonna put the
government the Supreme Court the
education department so if there's no
angels in here there's no there's no
angels in a lot of this process this
whole debate on student loan forgiveness
like just like all villains there's no
where's the hero all villains in the
story it's a horrible story but a
villain story but then when you see the
Sofi commercial after all this yeah
and they're there to help you and
they're so friendly we hope you get out
of debt by borrowing on our stuff
remember this get out of that you just
borrowed the debt yeah
you're right you're right no love loss
for the Biden kicking the can no love
lost for the education department no
love loss for so far for dadgum sure but
also a good reminder to start paying on
these loans
this is all not looking good right now
like we've been waiting for a long time
for decisions and as this is playing out
it's not looking good
at the same time we told you not to buy
crypto we told you to get out of debt
because
it's not gonna be forgiven
when all the Smoke Clears
you're gonna pay it
so quit acting like it's not there
denial is not a river in Egypt
you need to actually not be in denial
okay you're gonna have to pay it pay
your loan now as fast as you possibly
can you keep waiting on the calvary to
come over the hill and it looked like
Joe Biden in the lead it's not it's
Custer's Last Stand
they're not going to make it okay not
coming they're not coming they're not
coming you are in charge of your life
you have to fix your life sofa is not
going to fix your life they're coming
for your throat the government's not
going to fix your life they're going to
lie to you to get your vote and then do
nothing they do that all the time they
are specialists at appearing to do
something and nothing occurs that is
like a Washington art form okay we are
going to announce a new program today
that's going to have absolutely no
effect but we're going to try to impress
you with it anyway and this is they what
they do full freaking time up there oh
it's just ridiculous it's so sad to
watch it too happen with real lives
these are real people who are freaking
out about their student loans
waiting and I know a lot of people are
going to say well I can't afford to pay
it off get six jobs and the payments are
coming like the payments are coming
that's going to happen like you have to
carve out space you can't like you have
to pay those backs it's not going away
it's not going away bankrupt them you're
gonna pay it they're not going to
forgive them you should have already
done it and what you did just watch the
cast of characters here everybody in the
story is a villain you're the only hero
be a hero in your own story roll up your
sleeves get your butt in gear get these
things paid off and quit whining shut up
six jobs it's what normal people do it's
called calluses on your hands
wussification of America get out there
get it done seriously